[Musique]
une capitale suspendue au montagne
dans un pays lui-même accroché à des
valeurs profondément conservatrices
[Musique]
religieux sont visibles de partout un
rappel constant du poids que doivent
porter les femmes du Honduras et du
combat silencieux pour leurs droits
[Musique]
c'est un grand jour pour Claudia après
cinq longues années de batailles
judiciaires elle est au tribunal pour
recevoir un précieux bout de papier
le voilà son avis officiel de liberté
Claudia peut enfin dire adieu à son
dossier criminel
le fruit d'une lutte ardue encore
aujourd'hui l'émotion la submerge quand
il revient sur son arrestation
Claudia s'est présenté à l'hôpital pour
des douleurs à l'abdomen en un instant
sa vie à chavirer on lui apprend qu'elle
a perdu son enfant elle ne savait même
pas qu'elle était enceinte le médecin
l'a dénoncé aux autorités l'accusant
sans preuve d'avoir provoqué son
interruption de grossesse
j'ai quitté l'hôpital menotté et mon
enfant était mort racontait
le Honduras à l'une des lois contre
l'avortement les plus stricts au monde
l'interruption de grossesse y est
interdite même en cas de viol même quand
la vie de la mer est en danger
[Musique]
les avocats de l'aide juridique ont
refusé de l'écouter et ont voulu lui
dicter ses décisions
ils m'ont dit que la meilleure chose à
faire était de plaider coupable dit-elle
alors que je ne l'étais pas
[Musique]
chance de rencontrer une équipe
d'avocats spécialisée dans les droits de
la personne le cas de la jeune femme
n'est pas unique il est le fruit de tout
un système auquel ce cabinet souhaite
s'attaquer
je pense qu'il s'agit d'une chaîne
d'injustice dans un pays qui ne fournit
ni information ni éducation sexuelle
explique l'avocate
dans cette bataille les avocats ont
duriane ne sont pas seuls ce cabinet est
appuyé et financé par avocat sans
frontières Canada sans la coopération
canadienne il serait impossible de
défendre de nombreuses femmes aux quatre
coins du pays
canadien se demande s'ils pourront
continuer leur mission auprès de femmes
comme Claudia à quelques jours du dépôt
du budget fédéral à Ottawa l'incertitude
plane la promesse de rigueur budgétaire
se fera-t-elle aux dépens de la
politique étrangère féministe du
gouvernement Trudeau la politique d'aide
internationale féministe du Canada va en
quelque sorte vivre un test avocat sans
frontières Canada reçoit des signaux
inquiétants sa mission où Honduras n'a
été renouvelée que pour deux ans
l'avenir d'autres projets pour avancer
la cause des femmes au Guatemala en
Colombie en Haïti sont en suspens et
réponses d'Ottawa se font attendre le
financement et plus long à obtenir ces
femmes là c'est
qui ont besoin de ce coup de main
continuent à compter sur le Canada ce
n'est pas le moment de les laisser
tomber ça t'affiche par exemple c'est
une enseignante en Afghanistan un
regroupement de ONG a même lancé une
campagne publicitaire pour interpeller
directement la ministre Freeland il
réclame que l'enveloppe de l'aide
humanitaire passe de 8 à 10 milliards de
dollars par année d'ici 2025 depuis
quelques mois je vous dirais il y a
beaucoup d'anxiété parce que ben on n'a
pas on n'a pas de cette clarté on doit
mettre des gens la porte on doit arrêter
des Programmes puis il y a plusieurs
priorités mais je pense que ça manque ça
manque un peu de vision
surtout que tawa multiplie les
engagements à l'étranger plus d'un
milliard de dollars en aide militaire à
l'Ukraine des investissements massifs en
Asie
[Musique]
la ministre des Finances assure que la
politique féministe est toujours une
priorité mais elle ne s'engage pas à
augmenter le financement de la
l'humanitaire on a besoin d'une approche
responsable du côté fiscal
[Musique]
la cause des femmes se heurte à la
puissante voix de l'église chaque
avancée semble entraîner des reculs
élection d'une première femme présidente
a suscité l'espoir début mars la pilule
du lendemain a été autorisée par décret
présidentiels mais la mesure a provoqué
une réaction hostile de la droite
conservatrice
explose
cette représentant des Nations Unies
constatent une explosion des discours
très conservateurs contre les droits des
femmes un courant validé et amplifié par
le recul du droit à l'avortement aux
États-Unis des voies comme celle du
Canada deviennent donc encore plus
importante selon elle
a encore un pouvoir d'influence ou
Honduras squatel avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
il n'y a pas que les droits sexuels et
reproductifs il y a aussi le fléau de la
violence contre les femmes
[Musique]
Claudia a remporté une bataille et peut
maintenant penser à son avenir et se
trouver un emploi mais il reste des
obstacles sur son parcours elle rêve de
voir son pays changer
égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
pourquoi ça n'existe pas ici
demande-t-elle
l'histoire de Claudia en raconte tant
d'autres dans un pays où les femmes ont
besoin de tous les alliés possibles pour
faire entendre leur voix
[Musique]